* Stimmengewirr *
Wo immer er Platz für Papier und
Stifte findet, malt Thierry Bouvard.
Seine Familie sagt,
Thierry sei glücklich, wenn er male.
Ob das wirklich so ist,
weiss niemand.
Thierry ist Autist,
er kann nicht sprechen.
Sein Umfeld kann nur erahnen,
was in seinem Kopf vorgeht.
* Verträumte, lebhafte Musik *
Eines aber lässt sich
mit Sicherheit sagen:
Mit seinen Bildern
macht Thierry andere glücklich.
Wie aber? Davon handelt dieser Film.
Bas!
Ja!
(Frau) Smile.
Mein erster Drehtag
mit Thierry Bouvard.
Meine Kamera
hat eine unerwartete Wirkung auf ihn.
Good morning.
Was heisst "Bas"?
Smile.
- Ah, smile, smile.
* Unverständlicher, tiefer Ton *
Herr Bouvard, was will er mir sagen?
Wenn er eine Kamera sieht,
möchte er lachen.
Weil wir ihm sagten:
"Thierry, lache!"
Und Lachen ist smile ... - Bas!
- Und du sagst ... Okay.
Bas!
- Smile.
Du musst nicht lachen,
du kannst ganz normal sein.
Thierry, sag: one, two ...
- One, two, three.
Okay, dann ist gut.
Thierry wendet all die Regeln,
die er mühsam lernen musste,
manchmal etwas unflexibel an.
Jetzt, da dies geklärt ist,
darf ich eintauchen in seine Welt -
und seine Bilder.
Sein nächstes Motiv: wir zwei.
(Schwer verständlich)
Eins, zwei, two ...
Three, one ...
- One, two, three!
Nochmals.
Eins ...
- Eins, zwei, drei.
Welches willst du?
- Two, two, two.
Dieses hier?
- Foti.
Foti.
Ein Foto malen?
* Thierry summt sehr laut. *
Fängt er immer unten links an?
Nicht immer,
aber seit etwa zwei Monaten
fängt er immer unten links an.
Ich würde zuerst eine Einteilung
machen, wohin die Menschen kommen.
Das macht er nicht. Er fängt
unten links an - und es geht auf.
Er macht einfach.
Thierry ist 19 Jahre alt.
Kurz vor seinem ersten Geburtstag
verstummte er.
Seine Eltern
hegten einen ersten Verdacht.
Lange zwei Jahre später dann die
Diagnose: frühkindlicher Autismus.
Damals hatten Joan und Andre Bouvard
noch die Hoffnung,
Thierry könnte
seinen Entwicklungsrückstand aufholen
und normal eingeschult werden.
# Aux Champs-Elysees,
aux Champs-Elysees.
* Thierry versucht, mitzusingen *
# Au soleil, a midi, a minuit,
sous la pluie.
# Il y a tout ce que vous voulez
aux Champs-Elysees.
Gib mir die Taschen!
No turn, you have the list.
Danke.
Die Hoffnung auf ein "normales" Leben
hat sich zerschlagen.
Was gehen wir holen?
Was holen wir?
Holen wir nachher Thierrys Brot?
Brot. - Und Chicken?
- Chicken.
Früher war Shopping der Horror.
Einerseits wollte er alles berühren,
was die Menschen nervte.
Hier haben wir jetzt
einen Steinboden.
Wenn der Boden wechselte,
warf er sich auf den Boden,
schrie und bekam einen Anfall.
Im Laden ist es etwas peinlich,
wenn ein Kind schreit.
Wieso bekam er einen Anfall?
Er war nicht flexibel.
Aus irgendeinem Grund
störte ihn das.
Er begann zu schreien,
wenn er den Lärm nicht vertrug
oder wenn die Art des Bodens
wechselte.
Get bananas, Thierry.
And one hundred thirty.
One ...
One hundred. One ...
One ..
Was sind das für Gesten,
die er da macht?
Er hat das immer gemacht.
Viele Autisten machen das.
Das ist typisch für Autisten.
Manchmal macht er so ...
Auf Englisch nennen wir das:
self stimming,
self stimulatory movements.
Aber Sie wissen nie,
was in seinem Kopf vorgeht?
Nicht ganz genau, ja.
Aber es ist viel besser
im Vergleich zu früher.
Take it and put it on the banana.
Take that. Put it on the banana.
* Thierry lacht.*
Okay. Good boy. Alright.
Thank you, Thierry.
Okay.
* Lautes Summen *
Die Geräusche, die Thierry macht -
ist das Singen?
Das macht er immer.
Ich glaube, dass ihn das beruhigt.
Es klingt wie Singen, aber ...
Auf Englisch nennen wir das humming.
Dadurch wird er etwas ruhiger.
Du kannst helfen, alles auspacken!
Thierry
ist das Zentrum der Familie Bouvard.
Besonders eng ist die Beziehung
zu seiner älteren Schwester Pascale.
Thierry, hallo.
Fest, fest.
- Fest.
Man sagt, Autisten fühlen nicht,
wie es uns geht.
Aber er merkte immer,
wenn es mir nicht gut ging.
Er wusste auch immer,
wie er reagieren muss,
ob ich eine Umarmung
oder etwas Ablenkung brauche.
Das spürte er schon immer bei mir.
Nicht wahr, Thierry?
Das ist essbar, Thierry,
das ist lecker.
Also, schneiden wir. Mach mal so!
Wir haben jetzt ein Vokabular
entwickelt, das wir alle verstehen.
Wie nennst du Kochen, Thierry?
Thierry, was machst du? Kochen?
- Kochen.
So verstehen wir uns.
- Was gibt es sonst noch?
Malen.
Spannend ist,
herauszufinden, was er will.
Wenn wir ihn in der Freizeit fragen,
ob er baden möchte,
dann sagt er ganz klar: "Baden, ja."
Cheers!
Er sei ihr Familientherapeut,
das sagt die ganze Familie Bouvard.
Thierry
verträgt Spannungen nicht gut.
Können Sie erklären,
wie sich das äussert?
* Thierry schreit. *
Manchmal ist man gut aufgelegt,
manchmal nicht.
Manchmal mit
und manchmal ohne Grund.
Wir haben nicht das Gefühl,
dass wir streiten.
Wenn wir in einer Diskussion
die Stimmlage etwas erhöhen
oder etwas schnippisch sind,
dann spürt er das sofort.
Dann müssen wir ihm sagen,
dass wir nicht streiten.
Dann verlangt er einen Family Hug,
dass sich die ganze Familie umarmt.
So zeigen wir ihm,
dass alles gut ist.
Bis jetzt kannte ich Menschen
mit einer Autismus-Spektrum-Störung
nur aus Spielfilmen wie "Rain Man".
Vollkommen in ihrer eigenen Welt -
und irgendwie genial.
Thierry aber, so erfahre ich,
nimmt grossen Anteil
am Gefühlsleben seines Umfelds.
Genial indes,
das trifft auf Thierry zu.
Das gibt einen Weihnachtsbaum.
Vom Glatt.
Das ist eines
von Thierrys ersten Bildern.
Wir wissen nicht,
ob er damals sechs oder sieben war.
Er schaut am Computer
"Aristocats" ...
* Thierry spricht unverständlich. *
Doch, Thierry, "Aristocats".
Er malte es dann abgemalt.
Ich fand es damals extrem,
wie er schon als kleiner Junge
eine Mauer,
die nach vorne ragt,
die ein Dach mit Dachfenstern hat,
mit der Perspektive der Bäume,
die kleiner werden ...
Mit sechs oder sieben?
... hat er das abgemalt.
Es ist ein total hässliches Papier.
Er hat es vom Video abgemalt,
damals noch ein 4:3-System.
Den Rand des Videos
hat er auch noch gezeichnet.
Heute nimmt Thierry am liebsten
Fotos, Postkarten und Bilder
aus dem Internet als Vorlagen.
Für Thierrys Eltern sind seine Bilder
kleine Fenster in die Seele
ihres autistischen Sohnes.
Es war, als ob ein Brett
vor dem Kopf hätten.
Wir haben es gewusst, es erwartet,
aber in diesem Moment wussten wir:
Es ist passiert, es ist definitiv.
Ich hatte
immer noch die kleine Hoffnung,
dass er nicht autistisch ist.
Aber alle Anzeichen waren da.
Als es offiziell war,
dass er Thierry autistisch ist,
war das wie eine Bombe.
Joan und Andre Bouvard
nahmen ihr und Thierrys Schicksal
selber in die Hand.
Sie vernetzten sich
mit anderen Betroffenen
und setzten ihr Erspartes ein,
um ihren Sohn bis zu 7 Std. pro Tag
selber zu therapieren.
So lernte Thierry z.B.
Augenkontakt zu halten
oder sich nicht selbst zu verletzen.
Wir mussten Thierry beibringen, wie
er lernen soll. Das war schwierig.
Am allerschwierigsten aber war,
dass ein Experte mir sagte,
dass ich nur noch Schweizerdeutsch
mit ihm reden soll.
Wie kann ich meinem Kind
in einer fremden Sprache sagen:
"Ich liebe dich"?
... in German.
- Nein.
* Kuss *
Durch die Therapie zu Hause
und später in Sonderschulen
ist er ist flexibel geworden.
Die Struktur, die ihm sein
selbstgemalter Tagesplan vermittelt,
braucht er aber auch heute noch.
Thierry, was war heute,
was könnten wir hier reinschreiben?
Sollen wir "Film" schreiben?
- Film.
Schau mal, das haben wir
vorhin doch gespeichert:
Filmen.
Wo war das?
(Computerstimme) Film.
- Genau.
Jetzt kannst du es abschreiben.
Seit gut einem Jahr lebt Thierry
von Montag bis Freitag
im Wohnwerk der Zürcher EPI-Klinik.
Hier sehe ich,
dass er schreiben und rechnen kann.
Ausserhalb des Elternhauses
muss Thierry anders kommunizieren -
mit Worten, Gebärden
und mit seinem Tablet.
Es geht eigentlich darum,
dass wir wir ihm nicht alle Wünsche
von den Lippen ablesen,
sondern dass er selber
ausdrücken kann, was er braucht.
Das sollte zu mehr
Selbstbestimmung führen.
Wenn er sich ausdrücken kann
und merkt,
dass in seinem Umfeld reagiert wird,
ist das jedes Mal
ein Erfolgserlebnis für ihn
und führt schlussendlich
zu mehr Selbstwirksamkeit.
Was willst du noch schreiben?
- Puzzle.
"Puzzle" hast du schon geschrieben.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Malen gibt ihm Sicherheit,
er kann dadurch zu sich kommen,
v.a. nach einer
herausfordernden Situation.
Wenn z.B. etwas anders
als gewohnt gelaufen ist
oder es in der Umgebung
speziell laut war,
dann ist das eine wirklich gute Art,
um wieder zu sich zu kommen.
Jetzt kannst du zusammenräumen.
* Thierry spricht unverständlich. *
Super, alles zur Seite legen.
Thierry, warte mal kurz!
Wir sagen noch Tschüss.
Guten Appetit, tschau, Thierry.
- Bye-bye, tschüss.
* Lautes Summen *
* Unverständlich *
In seiner Wohngruppe lebt Thierry
mit drei Frauen zusammen.
Eine von ihnen ist Angela,
die mir sogleich das Du anbietet.
Angela, wie ist Thierry so?
Ja ...
Er ist immer so laut.
Ist er laut?
- Ja.
Stört dich das denn?
- Ja. - Ja?
Magst du es nicht,
wenn jemand laut ist? - Nein.
Gibt es auch etwas an Thierry,
das du magst?
Ja, er schenkt mir Zeichnungen.
Jetzt setzen wir uns alle zu Tisch,
Thierry!
(Zusammen) En Guete mitenand.
* Rock'n'Roll im Hintergrund *
Von seiner Familie
wurde und wird Thierry nie versteckt.
Heute gehen Vater und Sohn
sogar gemeinsam aus.
* Rock'n'Roll:
"Tutti Frutti" von Little Richard *
# Wop bop a loo bop a lop ba ba!
Thierry gehört dazu.
Man merkt ihm an,
dass er nicht gleich wie wir ist.
Für uns ist er eine Bereicherung.
Er hat uns
zu besseren Menschen gemacht.
Wir haben mehr Verständnis
und überlegen uns mehr,
was im Leben wichtig ist.
Es ist wichtig,
solche Leute nicht zu verstecken.
Man sieht ihm ja nichts an.
Er soll sich zeigen,
und die Menschen sollen sich ihm
vielleicht auch ein wenig anpassen.
* Hip-Hop *
Thierry tanzt gerne und liebt es,
mit seinem Mountainbike
die steilsten Abfahrten zu machen.
Am liebsten zusammen mit seinem Vater
und dem Rest der Familie.
Wenn man ihn tagsüber beobachtet,
gleicht sein Verhalten
oft jenem eines Kleinkindes.
* Hip-Hop:
"The Real Slim Shady" von Eminem *
Man merkt, dass er 19 ist,
weil er sich rasieren muss.
Sonst würde man es nicht merken.
* Sanfte, verträumte Musik *
Er liebt es,
in Kunstmuseen zu malen.
Das fanden seine Eltern vor Jahren
auf einer Reise nach New York heraus.
Willst du das malen?
- Ja.
(Mutter) You want this one, Thierry?
Don't you want to look for Picasso?
* Unverständlich *
That one, okay.
Okay. Okay.
- Okay.
Auch wenn er die Bilder
direkt vor der Nase hat -
wie hier im Zürcher Kunsthaus -
erst fotografieren, dann malen.
Warum? Nur Thierry selber
kennt die Antwort auf diese Frage.
Auf diese Frage
werden wir nie eine Antwort finden.
Das ist einfach so,
damit muss man leben.
Am liebsten
würde ich es wissen wollen,
aber ich musste es akzeptieren.
Auch im Louvre
hat Thierry schon gemalt.
Alle hätten gedacht,
er sei ein grosser Künstler,
erinnert sich seine Mutter.
Ich bin sehr, sehr stolz
und auch glücklich,
dass er glücklich ist
und einen Weg gefunden hat,
um sich - wie heisst das -
to express ...
... auszudrücken?
- Ja, genau.
Danke!
Er ist auch stolz,
weil er seine Zeichnungen
anderen Menschen, fremden Menschen
schenken kann.
Er möchte Ihren Namen.
Das hat er für Sie gemalt.
- Was?
Es ist ein Geschenk.
Thierry, hey!
Vielen Dank!
Schön.
- Coole Bilder, nicht?
Wow!
* Sanfte, lebhafte Musik *
So wie ich mich
in Thierrys Bild erkenne,
so nimmt auch er als Person
für mich immer konkretere Formen an.
Seine Art zu malen und sein Wesen
berühren mich.
Und damit bin ich nicht allein.
Schon zum zweiten Mal
kann Thierry seine Werke
in einer Ausstellung zeigen.
Heute findet die Vernissage statt.
Okay, das ist genial.
Wir haben ihm den Raum gezeigt
und haben gesagt:
"Thierry,
hier darfst du ausstellen."
"Thierry, da, Bilder".
Und er: "Da malen."
Ja.
Ob er es verstanden hat,
weiss ich nicht.
Aber ich weiss, dass er sich
über die Bilder freut
und wenn ihn Erwachsene ansprechen.
Look!
Der Abend wird ein voller Erfolg.
Seine Betreuer aus dem Wohnheim
sind gekommen,
Freunde seiner Eltern, Verwandte.
Und mittendrin,
in seiner eigenen Welt:
Thierry malt.
Seine Fans bedient er
schon fast professionell,
um so schnell wie möglich
weitermalen zu können.
Danke.
Danke vielmals.
Auf einer Skala von 1-10,
wie stolz sind Sie auf Thierry?
Etwa bei 11 - mindestens.
Es ist sehr schön,
dass wir ihm etwas geben konnten,
an dem er selbst auch Freude hat,
nicht nur wir.
Er kann seine Bilder präsentieren,
und fremde Menschen
haben Freude an ihm.
Und wir können zeigen,
was für eine tolle Person er ist.
Beeindruckt ist auch Künstler
und Kunstdozent Emil Müller,
genannt müller-emil.
Es hat so eine ganz präzise Art
des Verdichtens.
Weil er keine Flächen malt,
sondern Linien,
setzt er diese so eng zusammen,
dass es wieder zu einer Fläche wird.
Er macht aus einer Linie
eine Fläche.
Das ist etwas Wunderbares.
Thierry und seine Bilder faszinieren.
Mich hat es berührt.
Als ich die allerersten Zeichnungen
gesehen habe,
musste ich sagen:
"Hey, das ist genial!"
"Das ist genial!"
Es hat etwas, das ...
... ganz tief geht.
Es ist wirklich etwas,
das sensibel geführt ist.
Es ist eine ganz intensive Art
des Zeichnens.
Das ist genial!
* Stimmengewirr *
Von nahe betrachtet
sieht man in Thierrys Bildern
nur einzelne Striche.
Öffnet man den Blick,
sieht man ein Kunstwerk.
Thierry!
- Thierry!
Ja, super!
So ist es mir in diesen Tagen
auch mit Thierry selber ergangen.
Ich hatte die Absicht,
einen Film über einen
malenden Autisten zu drehen.
Jetzt sehe ich einen wunderbaren
Menschen und dessen Familie.
Ein Gesamtkunstwerk, sozusagen.
Wow! Schön, Thierry!
Schön.
Wer ist das?
Helen.
- Helen.
Und das?
- Thierry. - Thierry.
Viele Leute haben mir gesagt,
sie kennen auch Eltern
mit einem behinderten Kind,
das sei ein Geschenk.
Die hätte ich am liebsten
auf den Mond geschossen.
Ich wollte, dass Thierry normal ist,
dass er Sport treiben
und selbstständig sein kann.
Wow, super! Freust du dich?
Ja? - Ja.
- Okay.
Aber heute verstehe ich das
mit dem Geschenk.
Er ist unser Engel
und unser Geschenk,
und wir sind mit ihm glücklich.
Ui.
- Was "ui"?
Thierry.
Was steht hier?
- Thierry.
Nineteen.
- Nineteen.
Good job, Thierry.
* Kuss *
Good job.